so when the [ __ ] is bitcoin and ethereum
and all these cryptos gonna come back to
what they were two weeks ago a month ago
uh that is a very open-ended question
because they're tied to the stock market
right now they are tied to the stock
market why is that
um
because think of it like this like
where's the liquidity for the stock
market coming from from the you know the
money printing and that liquidity in the
stock market's going crazy and it
provides other funds to invest in crypto
and crypto scene is a speculative risky
asset so it's like the stock market like
did a line of crack
and uh yeah
so so crypto will mirror almost sort of
by the movements of what the stock
market does but there will be there will
be a time when it's decoupled from the
stock market
yeah
even with all the regulation and they're
talking about with the with the biden
trying to regulate it and and all that
[ __ ] in the news about it and
dude
couldn't regulate you know two two uh
two damp socks
i don't think they understand it enough
to regulate it and that's what scares me
honestly probably and you're probably
right i disagree a little bit i think
that we'll see a good comeback this year
in crypto i do think we'll start seeing
those higher highs this year before we
go into an entire
uh bear market if you will
but
i think that that crypto you know the
reason it tracks it is because so many
of the big boys are now here you know
like so much big money is now in crypto
it's like it's it's no longer
a question people like when's the
institution when the institution the
institutional money is in
crypto now and it's still growing
but for for the most part like
i think that
i think crypto single-handedly this time
around saved our economy
from going into complete despair
back in 2020.
like i really do believe that that's why
we started seeing that run up in crypto
and were people like how are we gonna
start start trading things
when you when you had like something
like
like 2020 happen you know i mean
having a new asset class and it's it's
happened before like it happened in the
1970s
it happened when before like mortgages
and real estate were like collateralized
and being sold around everywhere we were
going into an economic collapse and they
were like well let's just create a new
financial
industry and they were like
so we'll take mortgages and we'll start
trading them like stocks
and then a whole housing market of
products came out and people started
training this is obviously a much
grander scale right but i think that
there was a lot of behind the scenes
going hey cryptocurrency could save the
economy we could run this out a little
bit more and and also back in 2017 the
retailers controlled the market now
retail market is only 30 percent of the
volume if that it's the institutions
it's the bots it's the whales
and and they're manipulating it i mean
they will manipulate it as much as they
can it's very easy to do
and they will continue to do so until i
guess the regulations come in and then
you know the
the you know the jp morgan's the you
know official
official boys step in although some of
them are they're already stepping in i
mean even even with the reports even
when i was leaving like they weren't
really talking about it
i mean there was there was whispers
around it but now they're like full on
in their like in their company reports
they have whole crypto sections like for
financial advisors for for all that like
they brief on how to talk to your
clients about cryptocurrencies
how would the government regulating it
affect it what would it change
fiat gateways
that means exchange no more anonymous
exchanges well no that's basically dead
coin based reports to the irs okay um
and anonymous exchanges i mean they're
already going after uni swap this is
already okay they're already looking
into that
honestly i think as much as as much [ __ ]
as i give ripple and xrp you know i
think that they're doing us a favor by
keeping the sec occupied because i think
they're gonna come to finance finance is
right next up man finance is next up
they did you know binance did
a lot for the space man i remember
trading b b at five dollars
they did a lot for the space they hopped
in and went they didn't really care
about the regulations they just did what
they were gonna do made a bunch of money
and now they're the king of the space
the government don't like that you know
what i'm saying derivatives markets have
been closing ever since the first of
this year
across multiple countries from finance
there's only a little sus activity going
on derivatives markets
really power the crypto prices a lot of
these fluctuations up and down people
getting liquidated longs and shorts
and you know we're seeing this kind of
this kind of happen another thing is i'm
worried about his tether a little bit
you know tetherfud's been around for a
while i don't trust him i don't hold a
lot of tether if i can help it
we'll see but i think 2021 is gonna or
2022 is gonna be quite rocky in my
opinion i'm a little more not bearish
but i'm more like okay let's see what
they're gonna do with the regulations
let's see you know what projects they're
gonna come after and i'm sure it's gonna
have a cascading effect on the rest of
us before
we can actually see the industry start
to to grow in a more professional manner
yeah i don't like i don't like guessing
and and i'm not always right which is
which is why i decided to create a bot
company in the beginning
because i was like i'm i'm going to let
smarter people build something to handle
this off a set set of protocols and it
kicks ass
it does we've been testing it we've been
testing it now for
i think three months
and uh we did an alpha test with like a
small group of people and it got a 90
hit rate
which means 90 of the time was accurate
which is way more than i am
so i was super happy about that wow yeah
that's wild yeah it tells you
it basically what it does is it'll break
down a ton of different coins and it'll
tell you when to get in and out of them
and for the most profit you know
huh
300 300 in one trade some crazy [ __ ]
because he was just like we told people
like hey you don't have to trade dog
this is just for you to reference like
to see if you like it or not guy was
doing 100x leverage they wouldn't let me
in the chat i wanted to come say hi you
know but no we wouldn't let him in
i'm a bit of a host though we don't want
you in there tick-tocking
yeah that was a hard that was a hard
decision
no it wasn't you and jackson my homes
yeah to be clear we're not the brains
behind the bot oh god absolutely smart
smart guy actually uh
we met on tick tock all the people that
i've met on tick tock are people that
work with me now you know that's how we
found them you know crypto wendia was
one of the first people i ever met she's
massive done massive things one of the
best female voices in the space
an example i think for women who want to
get into crypto web 3 i think they
should really check her content out
because she's been through a lot like
she's the best the misogyny in the space
man like it's pretty bad it's pretty bad
dude you think like being a girl on the
internet is tough imagine people who are
chronically online
who are often times like deprived of
social interaction
uh and who have a bunch of money
harassing women like this it's a problem
i'm not gonna lie after like talking to
wendy she's done a lot she's been
through a lot so i respect her a lot and
she came on the team we're very close
with her
shout out to crypto wendio and we've
also got crypto weatherman who built the
bot we had a discussion about ta i was
like man ta's horse [ __ ]
it's astrology for men he's like cta
technical analysis technical analysis
i'm like these people drawing lines on
charts
[Music]
no no he sat me down he's like let me
teach you ta so we hopped in a zoom call
five minutes into the zoom call i knew i
was gonna ask him to come work for us
like
he his brain is is amazing and so is his
personality and you put put that
together you get a really kick-ass guy
who can do some cool [ __ ] and so he
built the algorithm for this bot
literally scrapes news sites and social
media to see if it's bulge or bearish no
one else is doing that
you